with discussion about some ccsd students
returning to the classroom
in the new year possibly in the coming
months there are questions
concerning whether children should be
vaccinated as well denise
yeah right now the current vaccines are
just for adults however medical experts
are now looking into how the vaccine
could affect
children kate houston is live in our
newsroom tonight with the latest on two
covid19
vaccine trials just for children yes for
weeks pediatric specialists and
organizations
have called for children to be included
in more rigorous studies of the covid19
vaccine
they say that this is a critical step in
the stopping of the spread of this virus
now in october the fda gave pfizer
permission to enroll adolescents as
young as 12
into its clinical trial the
pharmaceutical company says that this
will help them
further understand the safety and
efficiency of the vaccine
as of monday nearly 700 adolescents ages
12
through 15 have taken part in that study
this month
moderna announced it plans to recruit 3
000 adolescents between the ages of 12
to 17
for its trial i spoke to two local
pediatricians who tell me children can
often be left out of vaccine trials
so this is a step in the right direction
children are not little adults so we
need to make sure
that we're seeing a good immune response
and we also need to make sure that
safety concerns are addressed for
children it's critical that we have the
ability if we really want to get to this
thing that we like to call herd immunity
that we can actually immunize children
and we can
cannot and shouldn't do it until
children have been studied
we are currently in the very early
stages of these clinical trials
so it's difficult for pediatricians to
say when this vaccine could be approved
dr morgan stern hopes to get it in time
for the next academic year
now in the meantime doctors are urging
families to continue to wear masks
social distance
and wash hands frequently they say while
children are not at a higher risk of
infection
they can still get the virus and spread
it to others